So, one frequent question that we get is
now that you've found your WHY,
what do you do with it?
How do you use it?
Well, one of the things you want to do is
keep it all around you.
One of the things that I've done is
I actually would write my WHY on my desk,
next to my bed
so that I was reminded of it.
That's number one.
But also start talking about it.
I start meetings with it.
When I sit down with a meeting I say,
before we start this meeting
I'd like to tell you why I took this meeting
or why I called this meeting
and I refer to my WHY
and say how I believe
that this potential partnership
or this potential relationship
could help me advance my cause,
could help me advance my WHY.
It works every time.
It's extremely valuable in
resumes and interviews as well.
When somebody says,
so why do you want this job?
You say,
let me tell you why I do everything
and maybe tell a story from
your childhood or
one of the stories
that you told in the WHY discovery process
to communicate your point.
I used to do that in all my interviews.
I still do it now.
I start meetings, I start talks,
I start all kinds of things with it
and it gives people a context for
who you are
and where you're coming from.
It's a huge advantage
on resumes as well.
I've never really understood
at the top of resumes
when people write "purpose"
and they say
"to get a job at a top performing
law firm blah blah blah ..."
Of course,
that's why everybody's applying for the job.
Rather, use that space
at the top of your resume
to explain who you are,
basically WHY you do what you do.
It gives context to all the other
jobs you've ever had.
It gives context for who you are
and it helps us
stand out in the crowd of people
who have similar experiences to us.
It also helps us understand sometimes
where relationships fail.
Where we sometimes did things
or said yes the things that
in our guts it felt wrong
but if we compare to our WHY
we realize that
we should never have done it in the first place.
So use it
front and center.
Speak about it.
Tell the stories.
Use the stories as metaphors to
explain who you are.
Talk about it constantly.
Start meetings with it.